hello there good evening you're watching
the press preview it's a first look at
what is on the front pages as they
arrive well it's time to see what's
making the headlines that's with the
director of the demos think tank polly
mckenzie and the home affairs editor at
the times matt dathan they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's take a look at what is on some of
those front pages
well the times leads with a warning from
the foreign secretary liz trust that
russia's using peace talks with ukraine
as a smokescreen as she describes it for
war crimes
on the telegraph president biden
threatens china that there will be
consequences if beijing provided russia
with weapons to assist its invasion
and the express claims an exclusive with
the news of a royal offer for help of
ukrainian refugees coming to the uk
the financial times leads with the piano
ferry sackings and a comment by the
archbishop of canterbury that the
company's action was unethical
and the guardian also has this story the
business secretary has warned the
company of an unlimited fine if it was
found to have broken the law
and the mirror focuses on the cheaper
agency workers that were brought in to
replace the sac staff under the headline
a p and low pay
on the front page of the sun the queen
plans to spend more time in her scottish
home the headline
monarch of the glenn
and another royal story this one in the
daily mail the cambridges have cancelled
their first big engagement on their
caribbean tour in a row over indigenous
rites
while the star looks forward to the
weekend's warm weather with the headline
hot hot hot that sounds good doesn't it
certainly promising well a reminder that
by scanning the qr code that you'll see
on screen during the program you can
check out those front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
well we're joined tonight by polly
mckenzie and the home affairs editor at
the times matt dathan very good evening
to both of you nice of you to join us
here on sky news on a friday night we're
going to start aren't we with the front
page of the times and that uh photograph
of vladimir putin there polly at this
bizarre spectacle the rally that he held
at that football stadium in moscow
it was bizarre um it sort of had a
sort of worldwide whistling wrestling
federation kind of vibe to it lots of
hype and cheering
uh and he stood on a what looked like a
wrestling arena or a boxing arena right
in the middle of the stadium and and
gave this speech
uh in celebration of of what they claim
is a denuncification process of
of ukraine liberating russian speakers
in ukraine of course none of which has
any basis in reality but is the story
that russian leaders have been
propagating through russian state media
for the last eight years since that
annexation of of crimea it was you know
it's i think horrifying to see the way
that ordinary russians have been
caught up in these lies which have been
pushed on them by the state so
relentlessly and the and the power that
has to
to shape the narrative i think it's
incredibly important that um you know
alternative media sources find ways
where and however they can to get in to
reach the russian people and explain the
the lies that are being pushed on them
by this leader um part of the story
there matt also says that a lot of the
people who were in attendance at this at
this rally
are allegedly
public sector employees who have coerced
into going
yeah that's right it's obviously very
hard to verify anything that russia does
at the moment but um yeah the reports
are around 200 000 people there but many
people uh who i think some reporters on
the ground spoke to were forced public
servants sports to go at the end of
their shift or during their shift i
enjoyed this quote on one man who said
that most people here don't support the
war um i'll go for a bit uh but so then
i'll then i'll head off um it did it did
see there was a very sort of mixed
reaction from the crowd many people were
seen
leaving before it did it finished and i
it's it's obviously very hard to verify
uh what russians really think but um
yeah i guess i guess 200 000 of um out
of a huge population russia has i mean
it's it's not obviously a fraction of
population but um how many people were
there actually supporting
putin
no one knows and what i found it mean
it's quite sickening really the the
music that was played
one was headlined um made in the usa
sorry made in the ussr with the opening
line ukraine and crimea belarus and
moldova it's all my country um so i
think maybe it's vladimir putin trying
to rally his own country in the
knowledge that uh the war is uh he is
sort of his grip on the war is slipping
and he realizes that there are factions
of his own population who are starting
to protest obviously we saw the tv
protest last week and maybe he's just
trying to sort of show his own country
his own population that he is still in
control
interesting as well polly that it says
in the article this trust um
saying that the sanctions on russian
oligarchs are likely to be permanent
well i mean
what does permanent mean in this context
i mean i think what we would hope
is that russia can return to the family
of nations by potentially changing its
leader or most importantly changing its
approach
in a way it feels um
the the way that the oligarchs acquired
that wealth is through the kind of
complete messed up
voucher privatization uh as at the end
of the ussr and then the way that kind
of kleptocratic systems were set up to
to funnel power and wealth to those few
individuals
nevertheless you know i don't think what
we want is for us to be in a permanent
state of kind of a cold economic
conflict with russia of wanting to keep
russian businessmen and and russian
products out of out of europe out of
flowing into the rest of the world
but i think what liz trust is suggesting
is that it's very hard to imagine a
pathway back to being able to trust and
reintegrate russia when as she says you
know vladimir putin is is just creating
the illusion of these peace talks whilst
continuing
to
uh relentlessly bomb you know
almost obliterate certain towns in in
ukraine with no kind of sense that
actually what they're what they're
looking for is peace and it's therefore
very hard very hard to trust them
matt let's turn to the front page of the
daily telegraph of course the big power
broker here
china
we know that president biden was
speaking to
president xi
jinping uh earlier
today
where do we think this is going
well i think at the moment the western
western countries are really trying to
work out where china sits really in this
whole power play and um i think that the
next few days are going to be crucial um
to see how russia china really responds
to the to the war
and the telegraph reports um as as other
papers that china um is trying to work
out itself and china is a country
inherently reluctant to sort of comment
or interfere with other other nations um
affairs at least publicly and from its
politicians and obviously its actions
speak for something else but um
biden today and in his call was reported
to have warned that there'll be
implications and consequences of china's
if china does uh back russia's war and
aids it with military equipment and and
helps it dodge um
or circumvent uh economic sanctions um
what these implications and consequences
uh are who i mean is yet to obviously
seen but if if the west starts hitting
china with the same ferocity of economic
sanctions as it did with russia um i
think then that just hits and a
completely new level of um economic
impact for the whole world and and um i
think that's usually being warned that
this would be would have what
far-reaching consequences um for the
west as well uh and and
he was quoted as telling biden um that
he who tied the bell to the tiger must
take it off and i think that's quite a
worrying and dangerous kind of uh
quote there that um the war of words is
now starting to sound between the the
world's two biggest powers
yeah and and probably many people saying
that actually china's really
interested to see how all of this is
going to play out and concerns about
perhaps what china's intentions might be
towards the likes of taiwan for example
yeah i think it is
fascinating uh to watch china you know
the at the olympic games
uh there was this you know sort of
staged event between uh uh president xi
and president putin sort of coming
together to talk about an alliance to
talk about um the you know the the risks
of nato you know made a real play out of
being united together
and i think sen sort of shivers of of
worry across uh that nato alliance then
when russia took this extraordinary step
of just invading ukraine
china didn't immediately back them even
though as you say there are that they
have some sympathy for uh the sort of
the ethno-nationalist russian narrative
that ukraine really belongs to them
because there are some similarities to
the sense that there is a greater china
which includes taiwan
and tibet places that they believe
belong to them and ought to be kind of
fully incorporated into into the chinese
nation nevertheless they are still
kind of keeping their powder dry that
that quote matt used about
that it's sort of classic chinese
proverb isn't it about the bell on the
tiger is that sense that
this escalation has happened partly
because of nato partly because of you
know the warmth with which nato
expressed its openness to ukraine and
that sense which russia has absolutely
pushed that that it has a legitimate
sphere of influence uh a kind of
colonialist approach really to countries
around it that ought to just listen to
it and not face west um and that
therefore it's it is in the end the
west's fault of having aggravated putin
i think that's an extremely
damaging and dangerous narrative for any
of us to fall into in that you know
international relations are complicated
but invading a country is simply illegal
and wrong yeah indeed well i just want
to bring us on before we get before we
go to the break mat the other story
that's on a few of the front pages of
course uh perfect textbook example of
dreadful corporate pr isn't it the the
behavior of pno towards its workers
yeah and if it wasn't obviously for the
war in ukraine i think this would be the
front uh on the front of all papers uh
tomorrow um it's quite a shocking
situation 800 staff sacked within just
30 minutes notice on a pre-recorded zoom
call
and now the government is obviously
obviously facing a lot of pressure to
intervene and we hear tonight that uh
the business secretary has written
warning of um criminal sanctions against
the bosses and this now
but now we've hit
economic sanctions against so many
individuals in russia obviously that's
now raises the
sort of that
it leads to people to call for the same
scholar sanctions against these kind of
bosses who have just sacked so many
staff on the spot and um you can you can
see the trouble the government is going
to get itself in if it's uh it does
start uh pursuing pursuing that line of
um uh that the campaigners are calling
for yeah i think we're going to see a
lot more of that story next week aren't
we matt dathan polly mckenzie thank you
very much indeed